i do want to mention that a couple of
staffers told me they saw benji over the
summer and benji's lost an incredible
amount of weight to the point that some
people said that he's too skinny now
let's see
oh look at that wow
wow you are thin my goodness what how
did you do
what is going on what did you do
counting calories help helps me a lot
because if i don't count calories if i
get ambiguous
i i just say [ __ ] it and i start to bend
and and what kind of exercise are you
doing i've never liked treadmill but i
didn't like running i started walking on
a treadmill but very fast and the big
question i guess most people would want
me to ask you is are you getting laid
now yeah that's all like i've yeah
that's all going better you have had a
couple of successful dates yeah you're
[ __ ] did you [ __ ] since you got lost
all this weight i uh i don't want to go
too into specifics but i've been dating
really oh you're dating something
serious with someone i i we'll we'll see
someone yeah is this woman around your
age or did you find yourself a much
older woman or a younger woman what did
you find that's one thing that sucks
about getting older like like older the
older woman thing used to be so hot like
this older woman fantasy but now like
like older women are like in their
hundreds now so uh
she's younger i assume benji has taken
his shirt off for the new girlfriend
no because i've always said when you
take your shirt off that when i take a
shirt off in a relationship
that's my passive aggressive way of like
uh trying to break up
you're saying you've been ashamed to
take off your shirt and you leave your
shirt on in the bedroom
yes i i've accidentally like walked out
of the shower with it and she's like
she's actually very sweet about it and
like
uh you know no you look good you like
look hot and you know has she seen you
without your hat on i know you're
self-conscious about your your hairline
i noticed you always wear a hat has she
seen you without your hat yeah i might
on the
first date or two
i because i wanted to just like you know
reveal everything and i took my hat off
and uh she said you should put it back
on
and uh right all right she's an honest
woman but then but then as we
as we start dating now she's like she
likes it and she even like said she
she's she
tries to get me to have the hat off and
she's encouraged me to shave it bald
though which i i did i agree
do you ever wear the hat in bed i i
don't i generally have had it all
nice
benji thank you and uh good to see you
congratulations